الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي العقيد الركن
حاتم كريم الفلاحي عقيد حاتم اهلا بك يعني
رغم العمليات العسكريه المركزه سواء في
الشمال او في الوسط او في الجنوب ما تزال
فصائل المقاومه قادره على استهداف غلاف
غزه بشكل بشكل خاص بالتاكيد بالاضافه الى
بعض المناطق الاخرى في في اسرائيل هذا
يتوافق مع ما قاله جون كيربي يعني المتحدث
باسمه البيت الابيض ايه مجلس الامن القومي
التابع للبيت الابيض من انه لا يمكن
التخلص من حماس ما
قراءتك نعم تحيه لك ومشاهدي قناه الجزيره
نعم لا شك بان هذه الضربات هي تاتي تاكيد
لكل ما قلناه سابقا وقاله الكثير من
الخبراء والمحللين بانه لا يمكن لهذه
العمليه العسكريه ان تقضي على القدرات
العسكريه ل لفصائل المقاومه الفلسطينيه
خصوصا وانها متجذرا منذ فتره طويله ولديها
بنى تحتيه كبيره جدا تاتي هذه الرشقات
الصاروخيه حقيقه تاكيدا على ان المقاومه
لازالت تمتلك الكثير من القدرات وجاءت ردا
على كثير من المشككين بان يمكن ان
تكون الذخائر المتواجده لدى فصائل
المقاومه قد نقصت او او نضبت ولكن هذه
الضربات تاتي تاكيدا على ان المقاومه
لازالت تمتلك الكثير من القدرات ولازالت
رغم التو والعمليه العسكريه الواسعه
والقدرات العسكريه والتكنولوجيه المتطوره
في الكشف والرصد والمراقبه ولكنها تستطيع
ان تطلق هذه الصواريخ سواء باتجاه مناطق
غلاف غزه او باتجاه المناطق التي تشكل
اهداف استراتيجيه ومراكز ثقل بالنسبه
للجيش الصهيوني لذلك نقول بانه لا يمكن
القضاء على قدرات المقاومه العسكريه بهذه
العمليه البريه ويجب ان تكون الاهداف بانه
خفض خفض هذه القدرات يمكن ان يكون صحيح
صحيح ولكن القضاء لا اعتقد بانه مناسبا
لهذه الع الامريكي الامريكي مشارك عمليا
استراتيجيا في هذه الحرب و وهذا ليس سرا
هذا امر معلن من الطرف الامريكي وهو يقر
بفكره بقاء حماس كما اشرنا وان بشكل غير
مؤثر في هذه الجزئيه عقيد حاتم يقول بشكل
هدفهم
هو يعني جعل حماس غير مؤثره عسكريا في في
القطاع ولا تشكل تهديدا بين قوسين
لاسرائيل هل تبدو هذه اهداف ادا واقعيه هل
ما تزال تبدو هذه اهدافا
واقعيه نعم لا شك بان القوات الامريكيه او
الدور الامريكي او الاداره الامريكيه هي
مشاركه بنسبه كبيره جدا وهي راس الحربه في
هذه الحرب على مدينه غزه وهي من ترفض وقف
اطلاق النار وترفض اصدار وتستخدم الفيتو
وترفض وقف اطلاق النار عن طريق مجلس الامن
وتقدم الاسلحه والذخائر وكل ما يحتاجه
الجيش الصهيوني لاستمرار هذه المعركه
وبالتالي هي شريك اساسي في عمليه قتل
البدنيين والتدمير التي تجري في غزه هذا
اولا المساله الاخرى هذه القراءه
الامريكيه منذ البدايه نصحت الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بعدم الذهاب بعمليه
بريه لحتى لا تتحول غزه الى مدينه فلوجه
ثانيه وبالتالي كانت هناك رؤيه امريكيه
بانه يجب ان تستخدم العمليات النوعيه في
مساله الرد على حماس في تلك العمليه التي
جرت في 7 اكتوبر ولكن اصرار القياده في
الجيش الصهيوني والقياده السياسيه على
المضيء في هذه العمليه العسكريه يبدو بانه
حاله دون ذلك الان عندما تتكلم الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تتكلم عن مرحله هي اقل
كثافه هذه المرحله الاقل كثافه في رايي
الان يعني ما يجري الان من عمليه انسحابات
من المنطقه الشماليه باتجاه منطقه غلاف
غزه باتجاه المناطق الصهيونيه التي تسيطر
عليها القوات الصهيونيه هو عمليه الانتقال
الى المنطقه الامنه او العازله على شرط ان
يكون هنا هناك تسريح لقوات الاحتياط وان
تقوم القوات النظاميه بمسك المناطق
المحيطه بغلاف غزه بدءا من الشرق باتجاه
الشمال وصولا الى الجنوب وهذه المنطقه
العازله سوف تستمر لفتره تكون من خلالها
عمليات نوعيه بعمليات دقيقه وفق معلومات
استخباراتيه على ان يستمر القصف فتستمر
العمليه العسكريه في مدينه خان يونس التي
تعتبر حسب ما يدعي قاده الاحتلال بانها
مركز الثقل العسكري وا السياسي بالنسبه
لحركات المقاومه وبالتالي يجب الدخول
اليها ما يجري الان في القاطع الاوسط او
في القاطع الجنوبي هو عمليه توسيع وتطوير
للهجوم وهناك عمليه تقدم وهناك عمليه
اعاقه من قبل فصائل المقاومه لهذا التقدم
رغم الامكانيات الكبيره يعني عندما نتكلم
الان عن سماء غزه لا تجد كيلومتر واحد الا
وفيه طائرتان او اربع طائرات مسيره تقوم
بنقل الصوره والصوت ومراقبه كل شيء على
الارض يضاف الى هذا وجود طائرات الاباتشي
والطائرات مقاتله يضاف الى هذا القصف
المدفعي يضاف الى هذا وجود قطعات نظاميه
مدج بالسلاح والامكانيات والقدرات بفرق
كامله يعني فرقه 36 فرقه 162 فرقه 98 الان
في القاطع الاوسط وفي القاطع الجنوبي يعني
كثافه كبيره جدا لهذه القوات ومع هذا
لازالت العمليات متواجده في المنطقه ولا
زالت الخسائر يوم بعد يوم تكون اكبر
بالنسبه لهذا الجيش من اسطنبول الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي العقيد الركن حاتم
كريم الفلاحي شكرا لك l